this time we were able to agree on the
catch quotas and for the most important
fish stocks in the north-east atlantic and in
the north sea
i am very pleased that after the
two unanimous political agreements reached
at record speed for the baltic sea
in october and for the deep-sea species in
november we are still able to do so today  once again we managed
to achieve a very good
deal we spent two days intensively negotiating
and came to a very balanced
agreement
i would like to go into the implementation of
the bond obligations, which i think is
particularly important and
which is particularly important for all those
affected  It is important to us,
above all thanks to the very
constructive
staff member states, have been able to provide an exchange system for fishing quotas, which
minimizes the impact on other fisheries and at the same
time ensures sustainable management
today we have agreed and
phish  ing report on it is for european
fishermen 50,000 phishing in plenum